yeah i feel like lex luthor when i do
this this must be what he does it's
morning ritual every day
[Music]
i've gotten close i i buzzed down to
like a one or two every once in a while
you know i tease it a little bit but no
i've never shaved my head all the way
all of a sudden you wake up and that
widow peak that i used to have now kind
of started going backwards i didn't want
to believe that i was losing my hair and
so you kind of ignore it for a while
start at the age of 20 at 20 you're
supposed to have a full head of hair as
soon as it starts to happen to you you
start to think about these things you
definitely go through that
self-conscious stage where you're trying
to hide it i'm balding i can't be
balding i look older people are going to
think differently of me now because of
this i might as well just bite the
bullet and see what i look like all the
way bald people have said i probably
have a good head for it sometimes going
bald can look pretty sexy so i really
hope that i will look good you know some
people have the head for it other
people's do not and you don't
necessarily find that out until you've
gone there yeah let's uh let's shave
this head yeah let's try it shave it off
there goes nothing
i've never seen myself as a bald head
getting rained on by my own hair that
was a big chunk of hair that just fell
off i really don't know why i've never
done this before there am i good i think
now it's time to go full
all right let's do this the instruction
manual said we have to have this i'm
just going to go overboard i'm really
excited to see how this looks alright
moment of truth here
[Music]
we'll see about my girlfriend she might
not like it as much i'm kind of sold on
this right i haven't seen it yet but it
feels dope this is a weird feeling my
head is not used to being shaved it's
just my skin
oh yeah that's definitely bald oh
i like it wow
i guess it plays to the evilness
maybe
maybe definitely interesting thing to
get used to seeing yourself with no hair
i saved a lot of money on haircuts i
could feel the breeze if there was a
breeze in here i think this is something
i could do again i like the shape of my
head fortunately whether or not i like
it it's definitely easier than trying to
combat going bald if i saw myself on the
street i would think wow that guy has a
lot of confidence just to shave all his
hair off like that and not care
necessarily what people think i don't
care if i have bald long hair short hair
fully bald half bald doesn't matter to
me because i'm always true to myself and
that's kind of
why i don't mind this look because i'm i
like to think i'm true to myself
[Music]